okay you're a show today with me done of
course yes done say it more
what do you think about the title the
kelly clarkson show do you think we
should do something with that
yeah i mean if if it's my show then i
don't i don't know
i don't think it should just be your
name so let's change okay put my name in
there too
okay somehow like the kevin the kevin
the kevin hart
kevin hart's kevin hart's kelly
clarkson's show something like that yeah
okay your name first
yeah put my name first yeah your name
for assistant that's good okay it's
still leaning over there are you talking
about it that's what i'm talking about
all right
change it they change the graphic change
it yes they did kevin hearts there it is
right at the top there we go
top line i got it i got it i like it
okay well now we're also like here to
talk about fatherhood
okay so like maybe we should honor that
somehow we should
uh hold on can we do like a graphic
going to that because i took notes
oh you took it yeah i got like little
notes like oh okay
kevin hart's like uh i don't know like
fathers and kids or something like that
okay like something something with me
like driving conversation toward that
you just
put put something in there too of life
okay a tribute to red dead okay
tribute to rap dad okay all right who
who is doing that because i like him
we are good we are emmy-winning so right
when you say it it just
freaking happens i like that i like that
uh i mean the other thing
i don't know occasionally can i get hit
with a spotlight do you got a spotlight
spotlight yes we have a spotlight if i
want to get hit with a spotlight yeah
every now and then just to where i'm
just nodding it just where we can
kind of dull you out a little bit
hit me with a spotlight every now and
then when i'm talking
yeah and just make sure there's a big
lighting difference between me
and kelly there you go yeah let them
know who's important yeah just sometimes
when i talk i may
just want a spotlight just to i know it
adds to what i'm saying
okay it makes it feel more powerful it
makes me feel like okay
yeah see like look see my stance change
how the spotlight is doing
welcome welcome hey welcome to kevin huh
good to see you everybody yep i'm still
here just waiting for you to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever